Me fascinó y me pregunté: "¿Qué otra cosa podía hacer?"
¿Puedo hacer algo en el dominio público y lograr la misma reacción?
Así que cubrí la señal de stop cerca de mi casa.
La reacción fue salvaje.
La gente se paraba,
salía del auto para mirarlo,
se rascaba la cabeza y volvía a mirar,
tomaba fotos, y se sacaba a su lado
y todo aquello fue muy emocionante para mí,
por eso quise cubrir cada señal de stop del barrio.
Y cuanto más lo hice, más fuerte fue la reacción.
De modo que me obsesioné.
Estaba enganchada.
Todo esto era atractivo.
Encontré mi nueva pasión
y el entorno urbano se volvió mi lugar predilecto.
Aquí pueden ver algunos de mis primeros trabajos.
Me atraía la idea de mejorar lo común,
lo mundano, incluso lo feo,
sin quitarle su identidad o su funcionalidad
sino solo proveer un buen traje personalizado hecho de punto.
Y esto fue muy divertido para mí.
Fue muy divertido tomar objetos inanimados
y hacer que cobren vida.
Así que...
Creo que todos lo encontramos divertido,
pero...
(Risas)
llegué a un punto en el que quise tomarlo en serio.
Quería analizarlo.
Quería saber por qué dejaba que esto tome el control de mi vida,
por qué me apasionaba
y por qué otra gente respondía de esta manera.
Y me di cuenta de algo.
Todos vivimos en este mundo digital, acelerado,
pero todavía anhelamos y deseamos algo con lo que podernos relacionar.
Creo que todos nos hemos vuelto insensibles
en estas ciudades nuestras súper desarrolladas donde vivimos,
con estas vallas publicitarias y anuncios,
y enormes estacionamientos
que ni siquiera nos quejamos más de todas esas cosas.
Así que cuando tropezamos
con una señal de stop cubierta en lana
parece muy fuera de lugar
pero luego, gradualmente, curiosamente,
encontramos un punto común
y ese es el momento.
Ese es el momento que me encanta
y ese es el momento que me encanta compartir con los demás.
En ese momento, mi curiosidad aumentó.
Pasé de las bocas de incendios y de los señales de stop
a preguntarme que más puedo hacer con este material.
¿Puedo hacer algo grande, a gran escala e insuperable?
Y se me ocurrió lo del autobús.
Esto fue realmente un punto de inflexión para mí.
Siempre será mi punto débil.
A estas alturas, la gente ya daba crédito a mi trabajo
pero no había mucho
cubierto en lana o hilo a gran escala,
y esto fue, sin duda, el primer autobús de la ciudad cubierto en gancho.
En este momento, experimenté, fui testigo de algo interesante:
puede que haya empezado el bombardeo de hilos, pero ya no era de mi propiedad.
Era una tendencia global.
La gente de todo el mundo lo practicaba.
Y lo sé porque me gusta viajar a lugares
donde nunca he estado,
solo para tropezar con una señal de stop que sabía que no la cubrí yo.
Así que mientras yo perseguía mis propias metas artísticas
--esto es gran parte de mis trabajos recientes--
el bombardeo de hilos también.
El bombardeo de hilos estaba creciendo también.
Y esa experiencia me mostró el poder oculto de este arte
y me mostró
que existía este lenguaje que tenía en común con el resto del mundo.
Fue a través de una afición de abuelitas
--esta afición sin pretensiones--
que descubrí cosas en común con la gente
con la cual nunca pensé que podía tener.
Así que hoy les cuento mi historia
pero a la vez me gustaría transmitirles
que su potencial puede encontrarse oculto en los lugares más inesperados
y todos tenemos habilidades a la espera de ser descubiertas.
Si piensan en nuestras manos,
estas herramientas que nos conectan a todos
y en todo lo que son capaces de hacer
--construir casas y muebles,
y pintar murales enormes--
la mayoría de las veces
las usamos solo para manejar un joystick o un teléfono móvil.
Y soy totalmente culpable de esto también.
Pero si lo pensamos,
¿qué pasaría si las soltáramos?
¿Qué haríamos?
¿Qué crearíamos con nuestras propias manos?
Mucha gente piensa que soy una tejedora magistral
pero en realidad no sabía tejer ni un suéter, no lo domino.
Pero hice algo interesante a partir de la lana y el hilo
que nunca se había hecho antes.
Tampoco se supone que iba a ser "una artista"
en el sentido de que no me formé para serlo;
de hecho, me gradué en matemáticas,
Así que no creo que esto estaba escrito en mi destino,
pero también sé que no fue una casualidad.
Cuando esto me pasó me aferré a ello,
luché por ello y me siento orgullosa de decir
que hoy por hoy, trabajo como artista.
Así que al planear el futuro,
sepan que su futuro podría no ser tan perfecto.
Y un día, es posible que se sientan tan aburridos como lo estuve yo
como para ponerse a cubrir en hilo un mango de puerta
y eso cambie su mundo para siempre.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)